abel is up next in seattle washington
abel how can we help how are you guys
doing
uh shout out to tracy for paying off our
day hopefully i could get there too
yeah you can you can yeah so
right now i'm upside down on my car i
make about
24 an hour it's like 50 000 a year and i
just needed
help just getting out of this okay what
kind of car is it man
uh 2018 missy bc okay mitsubishi uh how
much do you owe on it
uh 24 000 and i wrote some negative
equity on to it also
oh lord chase how much do you um
how much is it worth about
17
okay what other what other kind of debt
do you have
right now i have no credit cards luckily
um
student loans i do have student loans
student loans that are in deferment
how much are those um it's about
50 50 okay
all right all right what else you got
man um
that's really about it i'm about to get
a raise in about
two to three years and it's gonna make
me go up to about 80 to 90 a year
all right okay cool great cool great
cool cool cool all right so here's the
thing
cars worth seventeen thousand dollars
you owe twenty four thousand dollars on
it because you
wrote in negative equity um do you have
any cash in your savings right now
just a thousand dollars i've been
watching you guys for the past
like months like religiously so i'm
rocking with you i'm rocking with you
okay cool um how long would it take you
to save up five grand
six months you make fifty thousand
dollars a year
i also own a home with my wife um okay
and i pay about twelve hundred
what is your wife the other side of the
mortgage she makes
about 80. okay yeah now we're at 130.
130. yeah bro hold on and um
so between 1 30 it'll take you six
months to get five thousand dollars
well she also has her own credit card
debt and
student loans that she's paying and we
just got married so we're trying to
find a way to balance our finances
all right well well we have to we have
two questions
we have two things we need to address um
it sounds like y'all are not combining
everything together
uh i'll let i'll let our married god
talk about that i'm a single guy i talk
to the single people so i'll let him
talk about well i'll just i'll jump in
very quick cause a.o can get you out of
this
and tell you what you need to do but
able here's what we teach when you're
married
it's it's our debt it's not her credit
cards it's not her student loans it's
ours so you know you're still in a
mindset and that's okay we're not
criticizing you but
this is this is this is leaving cleave
and and i don't know what your wedding
vows were but
we're joining together and it's not just
because of what we believe about
marriage it's because
we've got to be on the same page to get
out of this debt
or this is going to become bigger than a
money problem this will be a marriage
problem
i can guarantee you that so you started
off the call going i make 50. we didn't
even know about the wife we didn't know
what she makes no this is how this goes
so you need to give ao the new number
starting with
we make a combined income of 130 000.
we have total debts including whatever
mama's debts are that you just married
all right so i'd start over
and then ao can walk you through this
but this is a combined situation here
yeah real quick so what do you say
combined income
total debt you all have combined
income for the household is 130 i would
say combined debt
now would have to be about a hundred
okay all right cool great so there's
going to you're going to work to death
snowball man have you taken financial
peace university inside of ramsay plus
you in you have the i have the app i
have that i have the app
i have i haven't got anything else i
just have the dollar app every dollar
app
okay cool great this is what we're going
to do i'm going to have you stand online
madison's going to give you and your
wife
a free year subscription on ken and i on
ramsay plus to get you all in it
here's what i really want you to do i
want you to consider selling the car
okay you're going to take out a loan for
the difference of whatever you do not
and cannot sell it for
so let's say for an example you sell it
for 17 that means you're negative 7 000
you're going to take out a loan for
7 000 yes i am saying take out a loan
why because you're going from
24 000 in debt down to 7 000
debt in that car all right the reason
why i said save up 5k because i'm going
to take 5k
and go pay cash for a car you lower your
debt you don't have a
a monthly payment and then what you got
to do is you got to really work the debt
snowball because now let's say for an
example the car was the only thing that
you had
with 130 000 income i'll say yo let's
get very aggressive with attacking the
car but right now
if we can get this thing down to
thousand dollars
or five thousand if you sell it cash um
then i
i love that math because we lower our
debt
and then also we pay cash for a car
temporary
and then once you and your wife become
debt free get a fully funded emergency
fund
then you can go back out there and buy
you a better car cash but i want you to
stay on the line
uh madison's going to take good care of
you i want you and your wife
to go through this class together so
y'all pick a date night
and y'all just go through this together
and i promise you're going to learn a
lot from
ken myself dave rachel um and our entire
team here man but
such a great question